so for those that don't know
the troxler
counter attack
oh leech ass is so friendly
and informative
it's a line in
what looks like it's going into a fried
liver from the two knights
where instead of black playing the main
move d5
allows white to feast on f7 pawn
and then really cool things happen
[Music]
uh so i just discovered magnus had two
games in this on the chest
winning both of them
against one of the top rated players on
lichas
sergey jigalko
also thanks to all the the subs hey it's
leech.org
what's up leachat.org
shout out to leechass.org which is
the site that i'm using to stream on
right now if you're just joining we were
just watching magnus play chess
but now he's no longer playing so now
we're looking at his
like older games
we discovered two games where he played
the traxxar
opening as black
and unfortunately
yeah jigalco didn't play like the more
fun line
which is understandable i think most
stronger players will play bishop takes
f7
yeah masters database
but only chess i think knight f7 is
probably more popular
over a hundred and eight thousand games
so
let's look at this game
wait what
oh magnus also had this as white oh
that's cool
so he's won all three games in the track
sir two with black one with white
at least from the nectar scene account
karpov played this in 1983.
that's actually kind of cool yeah this
is a cool thing about the leches
database can really dig into
some history of some of these openings
i'm not sure what's more exciting
karpov playing the traxxar
or karpov playing rey enigma
anyway let's see what happened
engine doesn't like this opening but
it's very very tricky
okay so black's king is on e7
the reason for playing this as black at
first it looks terrible because you lose
casting rights
you lost a pawn
but the fact that there's now more open
lines
given that there's no pawn on f7
uh mainly the f-file and this diagonal
which can be used by the rook and then
the queen
and white's going to lose time having to
move the knight again
so queen e8
we're going to ignore the engine for a
bit
also it's kind of hard to ignore the
engine
look at this graph
look at this graph white was winning the
whole game
but magnus kept surviving and then at
some point
jagalko fell off a cliff
that's crazy
okay let's
can i turn off engine
okay no more engine
let's try and identify the points that
like oh
bishop f7
oh that's why queen g6 is a blunder
oh that's kind of nasty
at queen h6
yeah this can get really nasty 96
hitting the queen and the bishop and the
pawn
and hugging the king
and foss says yeah magnus doesn't know
theory so what's the theory
instead of queen g6
the move to play is d6
which makes some sense
okay so magnus was basically down the
queen
most of this game so magnus was playing
a traxler
and a botez gamut
but
yeah in in exchange for being down the
queen what does black have
uh two knights
actually white's up a pawn too
so magnus has two knights
for queen and pawn
[Music]
but this was a bullet game so
okay let's see
what happened
bishop trades for night now it's
bishop and knight for queen and pawn
white building up on the king side the
black holding on
g5 looks like a nice move
still holding on
it's a nice strategy when you're
down material like this
just hold on for dear life
man it's a triple battery gun
i have to play 98 i think
and look at these pieces
so this and this are defended
i don't see how
black defends everything here
king f8 so defending the rook losing a
pawn
how does magnus win this
yeah the goal is to identify the turning
point
he's still surviving
oh okay the rook is lost
knight h7
but magnus doesn't take it
what is this
wow so he does win the exchange
white's still winning though
oh no did white move the queen to the h
file
[Music]
no white's playing well
doh
king ji won
oh he had two seconds left
i was like wasn't looking at the time
stamps so maggie's just just kept
surviving until
jagalko got super long time
and then
counter
the counter botes gambit
oh no my queen
what a game
okay let's look at one more game
[Music]
is it this one so it's this one
oh this game wait a minute
this game magnus wins with the traxxar
in 16 moves
against the same opponent 3000 rated gm
let's see what happens
same line
okay bishop c4 slight difference than
bishop b3
now does magnus learn from his mistake
i don't know this game was before after
the previous one
okay d6 better move
i mean we're already like almost 10
moves into the game
so magnus wins the game in like five or
six more moves
i wonder if chicago is going to get
mated on f2
because that's slightly
tricky to see
at least for a beginner player
knight g4 hitting the pawn
three times
knight f7 wow
[Music]
obstructing the queen attacking the rook
man this goes for the fork
queen h5
now this is like the craziness of the
troxler where things are like hanging
left
and also left
so it takes oh no did white take here
no
the magnus is upper right he's
inaccurate
g6
check
we're gonna see king c6 king e8
so the queen's attacks now
[Music]
bishop a4 losing the
magnus doesn't take the knight because
of rook f1 so c6
and white resigns in this position
[Music]
white just ran out of steam
[Music]
and now this and this are hanging
and white's already down a rook
oh queenie yates
queenie it's inner accurates is rook
athletes or d6
ah rook f8
yeah it might be worth exploring the
theory someday
those were some fun games though
i might have to put this section
on youtube
magnus carlson plays the track sir
what does the computer think about this
game
enable
how do i enable
there we go
wait what white was winning the whole
game
what is this graph
was white better in the final position
no
the final position looked losing
oh this graph
only goes through
the graph kind of is hiding behind
behind something
refresh
hey there's a graph okay
so the turning point was this moment
white played bishop f7
which looks logical but it's kind of
wasting time
yeah because he just helped improve the
queen gave like an extra move
and then f2 is hard to defend
okay
so why was not winning this whole game
yeah final position was
minus 7.5 in black's
favor all right if this goes on youtube
hello to youtube let me know if you want
to see more content like this
where we just like look at magnus
carlson's crazy openings
be fun to do like a deep dive and
some other like maybe fun gambits that
he plays
also twitch chat says hi
hello
and electric eye says hello
[Music]
all the first time viewers in chatters
yeah if you're new here feel free to say
hi
hey more first time viewers
chad is so welcoming